kid flash is he gonna be replacing
firestorm on legends in tomorrow since
that's an interesting idea I tell you
that I can't tell you who is replacing
firestorm the only because we're will
make that announcement probably in the
new year I will say that it's not a
brand new character it's a character
sort of from plucked from somewhere in
the arrowverse character you've seen
before so stay tuned I want to know with
the new Titan show coming and the
mention of Bruce Wayne on arrow today is
there any chance we'll see the Titans
show in the air overs and if not will we
see any arrowverse characters I'm a
Titan show a great question again above
my paygrade the one thing I will say
this the one thing I've learned is Never
Say Never
I could not begin to tell you how often
we say to each other like we never
thought any of this was gonna happen we
never thought we'd see all these
characters we never thought there'd be
like a universe so I never say never but
in terms of like which characters can be
on which shows and what's part of the
universe above my paygrade and probably
that's a good thing Kord industries has
dropped a lot so any chance Booster Gold
Blue Beetle you never know I think you
know I will say both those characters
are characters we've talked about like
originally Ray Palmer who was introduced
on arrow he was supposed to be Ted Kord
and we went another way like so you know
booster and Blue Beetle all to be
characters really we you know we're
always talking about but nothing nothing
I can announce or speak to at the moment
you know it wouldn't surprise me if you
saw him at lesser back is eobard thawne
at some point on one of those shows
that's what makes it fun hey everybody
so we got some new Titans to talk about
some new characters they're bringing
into the universe a couple of them are
confirmed and then some of them
obviously as Marc Guggenheim was hinting
at they're thinking about bringing it in
the future so I'll try to differentiate
between what might end up happening
where Wally West probably ends up going
in what titans has actually confirmed so
if you're finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get everything
there's gonna be a whole
more tightened stuff coming really soon
too obviously in addition to all the
other DC TV shows and there is a new
round of that flash ring giveaway I'll
explain at the end of the video but
starting with the biggest thing first
arrowverse crossing over with titans so
if you guys didn't know greg berlanti is
producing titans with a different group
of people than produce all the other
arrowverse shows they're shooting it in
Toronto whereas most of the arrowverse
shoots in Vancouver which is a pretty
solid distance away most of the
arrowverse shows shoot about 23 episodes
of season legends of tomorrow is a
little bit less than that but they shoot
very long seasons Titan season 1 is only
gonna do about 13 episodes the comments
that Marc Guggenheim made pretty much
confirm that there has been no talk of
crossover as of season one you may have
seen the Titans Robin teaser video that
I did a little while ago they just
started shooting the first episode
that's why we got to see that Robin
costume because they have to show him in
Gotham before he goes off and starts to
form the Titans and they come together
based on the casting news and the
confirmations there's just so much stuff
going on with that TV show it's gonna be
so comic cookie it'll be awesome but it
seems so complicated that it sounds like
what they'll do is they'll just do those
first 13 episodes or so and then worry
about maybe crossing it over sort of
low-key confirming that they're just
gonna say you know what multiverse
explainer it's on a different earth
that's why none of the arrowverse
characters have heard of these people
and if they do wind up meeting it'll be
for the first time like who the hell are
you I'm Robin who the hell are you I'm
the green arrow so getting into the
wally west of it now because everybody's
like where's wally going is he going to
titans is he going to legends of
tomorrow one thing I've learned is never
say never this effectively means that
he's not going to go to Titan season 1
now obviously Marc Guggenheim was very
coy with the idea of which big character
would be replacing firestorm on Legends
Constantine coming in but he seems like
he's got to be a more temporary thing
this season they said that somebody
would be coming in to replace firestorm
this season so whoever it is it's
probably not Constantine now I'm really
hoping that it's not some lame character
like he says it's a returning character
from the arrowverse meaning that it's
somebody
on one of the shows right now so on the
upside they could take the vastly
underutilized Wally and actually do
something with them on that show or it
could totally go sideways and they cast
some lesser character that you totally
don't care about that's the problem with
the arrow verse now is there's like 50
billion characters but you really only
wind up caring about a handful of them
at any given time like if this
convention appearance that Marc
Guggenheim was doing they got a bunch of
questions about the flash the reverse
flash in Wally West not so many
questions about the other supporting
characters on the TV shows the other big
casting announcement that was made is
that it sounds like they might be doing
Donna Troy on Titans which makes sense
because she's a big Titans character so
eventually they get to her we just
didn't know if it was going to be during
season one because they've already
announced several characters like we
have Hawk and Dove as supporting
characters in addition to the core team
you have brother blood you have Ravens
mother there are a couple other minor
characters around the blood Haven Police
Department because that seems like where
the series is going to be set and if
there's only gonna be 13 episodes you
just wonder how many big characters
they're gonna try and shoe horn in but
in the casting announcement they use a
fake name so they didn't use Donna
Troy's name they said that she'd just be
a recurring character during season one
and become a series regular during
season two if it works out
hopefully it's Donna Troy but if you
wonder why people have been talking
about Wonder Girl on Titans that's why
but I don't think that they would call
her Wonder Girl if she came on the show
they would just call her Donna Troy and
they just make references to all the
different costumes and names that she's
had if you're not a big comic book fan
there are a lot of times when character
histories get really complicated there
are a lot of retcons Donna Troy is one
of those characters she's at various
times been a clone of Wonder Woman been
a magical construct just completely
insane backstory so whatever the TV show
winds up doing with her they'll probably
simplify that just a little bit and they
just have lots of Easter eggs for all
the complicated backstory but just
taking his comments at face value Marc
Guggenheim who is one of the most
powerful people within Team Berlanti has
said that nobody has come to him about a
Titans crossover yet
so Jeff Jones is producing that with
some other people they're writing it and
shooting episodes right now it's one of
the few series that Jeff Jones is
actively working on which makes me so
much more
about it they're still under the
Berlanti production umbrella but they're
just being treated like their own
special thing off by itself
so just multiverse explainer for season
1 there was also discussion of Superman
returning to the TV shows the Tyler
hoechlin version of the character he
said that that's always a political
discussion and it's always ongoing
because Henry Cavill is gonna continue
to play the character it's just a little
harder for the TV shows to use the
character just because they want to keep
him bookmarked for the movies now you
may have heard about the big DC EU
announcement this afternoon at Brazil
comic-con Warner Brothers did a
presentation of all the DC movies that
it's working on like it actually showed
a real these are the movies that you're
gonna be watching in the next couple of
years it if you saw the flashpoint video
that I posted a couple days ago about
how their plans have changed just a
little bit and what they're retooling as
they move forward with the movies the
film presentation at Brazil Comic Con
just confirmed all of that meaning that
all of their films that they were
originally planning on making in the
next couple of years are still on the
schedule with like two or three
exceptions the only ones that they did
not show during the real were the cyborg
solo movie the Justice League sequel in
all the Suicide Squad spin-off movies
and that includes all those multiple
different Joker movies that you may have
heard about like the Leonardo DiCaprio
Joker movie the Gotham City sirens movie
but aside from those few movies
everything else is still on the schedule
Ezra Miller even confirmed to a fan at
that convention that they were starting
work on flashpoint
really soon in Henry Cavill said that
they were starting to develop the next
Man of Steel movie really soon too so
he's going to continue to be Superman
Ezra Miller will continue to be the
flash I know Ben Affleck is sort of up
in the air he'll probably do flashpoint
after that we'll see but it sounds like
they might go with the different Batman
by the time they get to that Matt Reeves
Batman movie I leave all your requests
in the comments below there'll be new
Walking Dead finale video tonight in
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner evil more tea please private
message me so I can get your contact
details there was a new round in this
video I'll just name the winner the next
time I post a DC video but to answer
your question yes I totally loved the
last Jedi but I don't want to give it a
number rating because I'm still chewing
on it and I'm not
to post my review until Tuesday so
that's when my non-spoilery last jedi
video will post but until then you can
click here to rewatch that Titans teaser
video that I did and you can click here
to learn all about flashpoint in what
they're changing behind the scenes at DC
Comics and the way they make those
movies thank you so much for watching
everybody to stay awesome I'll see you
guys tonight
you